there's a new trailer
for a new show
on showtime it's going to delve into
some of the racial issues in america
and i haven't seen the show yet it
hasn't come out
but from what i gather
the thesis of the show
is that white people are really
really bad
i think what annoys me most about white
people is when they pretend like they're
the victim
what's also annoying is when they you
know when they kill us
what is fragile about whiteness when
everything has been constructed around
it
every part of who i am has been
distorted or criminalized it's really
just a bunch of white lies
we're starving the capital
you're not patriots you're ridiculous
one of the definitions of american
whiteness is ignorance
white people we are not your problem
you are should white people today feel
any responsibility for slavery
hell yeah
white jesus or black jesus jesus was not
white think of geography ain't no way
jesus walked around with blonde hair and
blue eyes
[Music]
those white people
those white people make me so mad white
people are
they're annoying
right that's that was one of the claims
just in this what 60-second trailer
white people are annoying
they're stupid they're ridiculous
they're ridiculous you ridiculous white
people they're ignorant that's the
definition of whiteness when you're
white you're ignorant so claims this
documentary on show time
you just you're just oh and you're
in slavers you enslave people
and you know the most annoying part of
all is when they play the victim
when they pretend that they're being
victimized you know
it seemed to me
that
if we're in a society now
where the only racial group
that you are permitted to legally
discriminate against also you can sort
of discriminate against asians in
college admissions though it's
that's that's a little
that that's only because the asians got
lumped in with the whites that's being
worked out in the courts right now but
if basically it's the only racial group
you can legally discriminate against and
maybe more importantly it's the only
racial group that that it is socially
permissible to insult constantly
including on
i think you
you might be the victim group
look we're all you know it's a fallen
world we all suffer we got to deal with
it no one should
should view themselves as a victim but
if one of these groups is going to be a
victim
and you're going to make claims about
victim it would seem that the the that
the only racial group that you're
allowed to
discriminate against and go after and
treat like second-class citizens
that might be the victim group right
imagine the show i don't even want to
say it i don't even want to say it
because it's so it's so you roll your
eyes when you say
you know imagine if the shoe were on the
other foot but imagine just imagine for
a second you're watching the showtime
trailer that says you know the worst
part about black people
you know what really annoys me about
mexicans
you'd go you'd be sent to gitmo
you wouldn't just get your show canceled
you would be
you would be sent to some prison camp
somewhere that would be so socially
unacceptable
why so why why does this happen i think
white people i think they're the
majority of america still not by a lot
but still by a little bit so why why is
this i the reason for it is that
white people have a very low racial
consciousness there was a study that
came out of pew research not that long
ago that measured how
important race was
to someone's identity
and for black people it was over 70
percent
said it was somewhat or very important
for
uh hispanics and asians it was over 50
and then for white people it was 15 just
15.
so it's just very very low
on the one hand what the left claims is
whiteness doesn't exist white people
it's a completely fake racial made-up
category and then on the other hand they
say
you are white you can never escape your
whiteness and you're evil because of
your whiteness and we're going to treat
you differently because you're white
obviously those are contradictory things
and the left is just trying to have its
cake and eat it too you saw at the end
probably the most
frivolous claim there was they bring up
jesus you say why are you bringing up
jesus
when you're talking about your crazy
racial diatribe they say man people say
that jesus is white no no actually what
they say is jesus said that jesus jesus
people say that jesus was white but he
wasn't white look at the geography
insinuating what that jesus was black he
jesus jesus is a jew
it's pretty clear if you read the book
it's pretty clear jesus is a jew when
you use the phrase jesus was
that's usually a red flag that the
person who is speaking does not know
very much about jesus or christianity
because jesus lives
that is the essence of the story that's
the essence of the religion is that he
rises from the dead
and lives
he is he's the divine logic of the
universe
he is
the second person of the holy trinity i
am that i am
why do they bring up religion in this
crazy racial diatribe because it always
comes back to religion
i do not
have a high racial consciousness i do
not consider politics
primarily or at all really significantly
through the lens of race
i consider it through the lens of
religion and in my religion there is
neither jew nor greek nor slave nor free
but all are one in christ jesus that's
the christian view of things the whole
idea of
racism and opposing racism it comes out
of christianity every other civilization
in the history of the world everywhere
on earth is very very very racist we're
the only one that's not
and and now because the left is
attacking christianity trying to kick it
out of our society and out of the public
square this is what you're getting
you're going to get more of it more
black identitarianism more mexican
identitarianism you're probably going to
get more white identitarianism too
that's the future they want do you want
to be part of that no well if not you
need
you need an alternative kind of pile i
think i think we had a good one but the
left wants to get rid of it did you like
that clip
i'm glad you liked that i liked the clip
as well i liked that you liked it if you
want to get more of them subscribe get
notifications
right here ring that bell
if you don't get notifications because
our friends at youtube don't want you to
for whatever reason head on over to
apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play wherever you get your audio
podcasts subscribe to the michael
knowles show leave a five star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you